thank you very much indeed
Hannah thank you all for being here
wonderful to see Cadogan Hall filled
with people for this event tonight I am
absolutely delighted to be your host for
this evening and to have these two
wonderful speakers with us James Rhodes
a concert pianist with frankly a cult
following I think you call it that no
that means ardent and so much more
his debut album razorblades little pills
and big pianos went to number one on the
iTunes chart as have all six of his
albums and he'll be signing copies of
his latest one after the event today now
as well as performing around the world
as of hereness James is also a
best-selling writer and a TV and radio
presenter his memoir instrumental a
memoir of madness medication and music
was the subject of an aggressive high
court injunction which James had to take
to the Supreme Court to win and publish
I'm delighted to say it's gone on to
become an international bestseller it's
being adapted for the big screen he's
also the author of how to play the piano
which is part of a series called little
ways to live a big life and his latest
book fire on all sides wonderful read I
couldn't recommend it highly enough
insanity insomnia and the incredible
inconvenience of life reached number one
in Spain in its very first week of
publication and the accompanying album
is also a number 1 on iTunes then we
have Armando Iannucci I'm sure he'll be
very familiar to all of you at one of
Britain's most celebrated comedy writers
and producers he's the creator of things
like veep the day-to-day Alan Partridge
the Saturday Night armistice and of
course the thick of it are the producer
credits include such classics as on the
hour and the Mary Whitehouse experience
now we're very lucky to have both of our
speakers here tonight particularly
Amanda who's hot off the plane he's been
in
the US and most recently gotten Berg and
he's back on the plane tomorrow to
rotterdam promoting his satirical film
the death of Stalin which does Simon
Russell Beale Michael Palin and Steve
Buscemi is so filmed so good that it's
been banned in Russia and I think that
tells you all you need to know he as
well as nothing if not a polymath in
2016 he released his first book The
Audacity of hype which explored sleaze
bewilderment and other 21st century
tales not the accents of the denizens of
Sloane Square his latest book hear me
out is a joyful account of his
adventures in listening for classical
music over the course of many years
Armando I should say is also the proud
recipient of grade 1 piano so a warm
welcome to you both
[Applause]
I want to start with something that you
both allude to in your book which is
this idea that a love of classical music
is something that needs to be really
fervently apologized for something
almost to be ashamed of I mean James you
have been such a champion of classical
music but you do say that every time you
mentioned how much you love it you feel
an apology coming on the entirely
undeserved reputation it has got makes
saying you listen to it and enjoy it
almost like a confession and Amanda you
to talk about this act of defiance
against the keepers of the cool and you
say I keep meeting people so battered by
the collective imperative only to admit
liking what the whole world is telling
you to like that they sneak out to
classical lunchtime concerts with all
the guilt of a Victorian clergyman
desperately hunting a crack den yes
that's the weak more hole the crack down
but I occasionally visit in disguise on
a Monday lunchtime yes well why do we
need to be in disguise about it why the
apology I well I mean for me it's it's
it's it's a sense of I mean there's a
ritual about it isn't there going to a
classical concert that you break down
but but you know conventionally there's
so much there if you're new to classical
music I think people feel excluded by it
as if people are saying well unless
you've got the score and brought it
along this isn't for the likes of you
you know there's that sense of and then
you come in and nobody speaks you know
everyone sits down and someone comes on
and doesn't say anything but sits down
and then if it's an orchestra more
people come on and then the conductor
comes on and doesn't say anything and we
start and and I think that puts a lot of
people off that's what I feel James
you've done more than anyone I can think
of to break down those barriers and to
get the message out that classical music
can actually be something that can not
only save lives but enrich lives and
enhance lives any life irrespective of
who you are what your background is what
your education is yeah I just don't I
don't like the word classical I mean
music is music the minute you put the
word classical in front of it at some
point and I can't pinpoint exactly when
classical music was appropriated
by a certain kind of person who wants to
see it as a kind of elevated art form
and their two ends there's the very
sacred you know God forbid you don't
wear a tie and you make a noise and you
need to know what a cadenza is and the
Sonata form in Beethoven's Vienna and
when to applaud there's that side which
is very very stuffy and then there's the
really apologist side which is these
kind of assholes on Classic FM who'll
play you know waltzing matilda on the
guitar and say this is classical music
or this is the famous bit off the whole
versed because actually you're a little
bit too dumb to handle a 25-minute
symphony you know so we're sorry this is
classical and there were all these rules
like um armando says it's like before
you even get through the door if you
don't know anything about classical
music and you think alright where to
start
Beethoven's fifth symphony everyone
knows that and you go to Spotify you go
to iTunes they're 400 recordings
of it with ridiculous album covers like
conductors like burning and that's and
then it even find it through the
metadata and all of that wade through
that's also the point you look at it and
you go hang on presto a - oh that four
tracks is this four people and then you
just go I'll forget it and you buy the
50 best chill-out classics
yeah which is the worst thing in the
world so classical music apologizes for
itself because for all of the talk about
wanting to open it to new audiences the
people in the they're awful people in
the classical music oh wow yeah the
majority of awful people and they don't
want new audiences at all it's part of
the reason I have played being played I
think once on classic FM in seven years
because they just think um whenever
anyone says actually what you're doing
is not helping the cause it's just
promoting your own record labels and
I'll give you a perfect example the
classic Brit Awards a few years ago they
had it and Lang Lang who's an amazing
pianist no one would deny that he played
a shop and polonaise and because it's
the big classic music event it's on TV
even though it's at like a TV for at 11
p.m. everyone gets very excited because
classical music on TV and because it's
on TV it had to be under three minutes
and so he ripped and edited he just
missed out half of the pot amazed he
didn't find one of any one of hundreds
of pieces of music that v under three
minutes he took the most famous piece
Chopin wrote didn't say I'm gonna edit
this down and played it because Classic
FM I said well you know what it has to
be under three minutes and so that if
that's not an apology for classical
music I don't know what it and it breaks
my heart that they thought you write
about the children thing because
children are actually they don't want to
be talked down to and they don't want
simplified hey this this represents an
elephant or this music is like a circus
isn't it they very I mean into gaming
which is about the most sophisticated
way narrative form there is with all
that many levels and you're under
contribu know they like things that are
complex and I remember once in the car a
bit of Ligety came on the radio and it
was like you know it's it's very you
know modern it's dissonant it's but it's
it's it's amazingly entertaining and to
my son who was about five or six I was
trying to simplify and I said this
sounds a bit like sir bees buzzing
doesn't it and they went no it sounds
like a lot of penguins fighting for a
fish and one of them's caught it and he
was absolutely right ahead as a program
note right side but you raise such an
important point because before children
know that they're not supposed to like
this or before they're told that they
you know it's only for pot people or
whatever it might be that gets drummed
into them their response to the music
like most human beings response to the
actual music is immediate and valid and
joyful and and the big the big much
bigger point to all of this is this
begins and ends with music education
which here with this audience I'm sure
it is not really an issue but nationwide
and the government successive
governments not just here but all around
the world from Argentina to Germany
Christ Germany it's in crisis its
hurtling off the edge of a cliff and
the government here were very very clear
in 2012 in black and white they said
every child every child from every part
of the country no matter what their
background will have the opportunity to
learn a musical instrument a complete
lie
it was just a complete lie thank news at
fate from much worse than fate news you
know how they get around it I've seen
this with my own eyes occasionally
there'll be a classroom of 30 kids and
for 20 minutes once a week they'll throw
in three ukuleles I'm not even joking
and I'll share the ukuleles you know one
to every five children they'll strum it
for a few minutes and then they took the
box and say that was our music lesson I
was more about the importance of this
but this really matters doesn't it I
mean James you've been extraordinarily
frank and candid and brave about talking
about how music has actually saved your
life and for you Armando music brings
dead people back to life is how you were
the wonderfully well arrive it yes it's
that mystery I think of music that's for
me is is part of its appeal without
trying to get too mystical I'm just
fascinated by the idea that a it's just
it's noises you know with with a worker
with a painting or with a play or there
is some kind of representation so
there's some way of identifying what it
means or there's enough clues to try and
work out what is trying to be convey but
with music for me it's just mysterious
that you can put certain sounds and
noises and Sunway and it has the same
general effect on people they makes them
feel happier or makes them feel sad or
it excites them and and I just find that
I find that really mysterious and I love
that that mystery pirate in that you can
actually boil it down to words and the
other thing is listening to and you're
right classical music is like too narrow
temp because you were talking about
music from the last 500 600 years to be
able to know these artists we listen in
to that piece of music and thinking that
is a sound that someone 300 400 years
ago also heard that's what I find kind
of exciting about it and actually you
cited a developmental psychologist in
your book David Hargreaves who argues
that there's something innate in music
it's very easy I mean Leonard
Bernstein's talked about universe
grammar it's an easy thing to throw
around this idea of music as the
universal language and I find myself
endlessly saying that people to roll
their eyes at me but actually what you
both argue so powerfully for is that
there is this sort of innate power that
music has over human beings as you quote
it under a deep structure that triggers
activity in the brains of anyone who
hears it whether they're from Cheshire
or Chad you're from North London and
Glasgow respectively how did you first
encounter classical music and was it an
instant love affair yeah and like come
on they said it goes beneath words it's
pre verbal and it's not it's bigger than
music that's the point about children
and music whatever whether it's
classical or whoever it doesn't make any
difference you see how they innately
respond to music and study after study
has shown that it has a dramatic effect
on well-being on discipline on focus on
literacy on numeracy on so much more
than just learning an instrument in my
case I found an old cassette because I'm
really old with a piece of bark on it
and and it changed everything for me and
because it because it goes underneath
words and like Armando was saying it
tells a story that often times we still
as adults we don't have words for but
there's a feeling that's anchored
underneath it and and that's why it's so
important that's why it baffles me that
Ofsted don't care about music it baffles
me that every child in this country
doesn't have access to music because the
price we're paying is that an entire
generation not only will they not know
who bark is they went on what a violin
looks like let alone sounds like and we
talk about building a four hundred
million pound concert hall another one
in London which is five years of the
music budget nationwide I mean it's it's
insane
it's especially criminal in a way
because we have so much evidence that
proves as you say the benefits of
classical music education on any aspect
of a child's development and it's not
about creating more musicians and it's
kind of intangible what it does you know
it has actually a powerful effect but
you can't
to fight what that effect is and
therefore it doesn't fall within how
education is measured now 25
qualifications towards employment but
we've just at the moment that we hold
Venezuela a point is ma quit but they
all know this like is there any single
person in this audience who would put
their hands up be brave enough to put
their hand up and say actually I don't
think music education is important at
all anyone like I would I would love to
hear your reason for that because it's
I've worked in schools I've been as good
if you take a kid
who is eight years old who's not
particularly academic who's not very
athletic he's not very popular and you
give him an instrument or her an
instrument a flute a violin a trombone a
piano whatever even a ukulele even a
ukulele absolutely it's like a gateway
drug to the and and then you put them in
a suit in an orchestra you form a school
orchestra and you give them a solo and
almost overnight that kid grows three
feet taller it gets more confident the
kids who never used to want to talk to
him are helping him tune up and rehearse
there's Timo that you can't imagine the
change it has and that's just in the
school and then that you move into their
home and you see what the siblings are
like around it and what the community as
a whole is like and that he's practicing
with his dad and he's doing work with
his mom and his other friends and it's
it's a literally it's a life-changing
experience which makes it all the more
bizarre that we are still having this
debate in 2018 also the opportunities to
learn are much greater knowing that you
can go on YouTube you can watch piano
lessons on YouTube you know you
discovered music through your local
library it was my local ya Xing
conversation at the end of library oh I
know that was it was the LP it wasn't
even a cassette tape it was a LP
collection yes I mean I I grew up in a
kind of small tenement flat I had two
brothers and younger sisters it was and
and I shared a room and my brother he
was into you know deep purple and pink
floyd and all the colors king crimson
and and you know which is fine but I
never quite I mean ever quite jolted me
you know it sort of and I wondered why
am I not reacting to this the way
everyone's meant to react and it was at
a school it was just a music
appreciation class at school that
happened so seldom and and I looked
forward to them every time I knew one
was looming and I remember the first one
I went to and the teacher just put a
needle down on a vinyl recording of them
just Holst's the planets I mean it was a
fairly basic well known but I was like
thinking that's my noise that's it I
haven't heard this before and I want to
you more of it's the it was actually the
Orcas to the sound of an orchestra
playing and the complexity of it but the
energy behind it and and then this
library opened up just down the road
he'll head
library with a massive gramophone
collection still exists does the grammar
for the line
does I I must pop in and see if they
still have a record collection and that
was just my education because you know
it was free
I could try stuff out I could experiment
I could take something home and if it
didn't like it I hadn't spent whatever
it was six quid on and there was music
and schools and they were just the
concerts and I worked in a school a
little while ago where they literally
had no music at all
there was no and and when I said to the
headmistress if I pay for five years out
of my own pocket to get an orchestra and
get it up and run and get everything you
need and would you would you do it and
we came up with the figures and she just
laughed and said no of course not we'd
spend that money on maths and English
because that's all off we live or die by
that as far as Ofsted is concerned
because it's not just the instruments I
worked in a school where kids couldn't
take instruments I'd given them home
because mum would sell it to buy crack
and then you have to store it in schools
so you need storage you need lockers and
then you need insurance a whole host of
problems that all the talking in the
world isn't going to fix but government
could relatively easily and relatively
quickly and cheap change yeah it's not
expensive they could do it and they
don't but in Russia the the commitment
to art to ballet to music huge
literature poetry yeah it's huge
it's in their blood and I brought a
libretto for an operative commissioned
originally by coma shopper in Berlin and
I remember going to see their opening
night and it was it was another Ligety
was Ligety opera so quite AB avant-garde
modernist piece the mayor of Berlin was
there for the opening night of course he
was it's the mayor of Berlin but of
course we wouldn't get a politician
wanting to be seen at an opera party
part goes back to that shame thing
that's fine I'll go to a football match
I might talk about a movie I went to see
or I I'll sneak into the theater but I
definitely can't be photographed at an
opera or a classical concert of course
for Justin Trudeau who's been very open
in his love and Emanuel McCall maybe the
tide is turning
who do we have Michael go I mean
but really I thought he'll sneak off to
the Opera and pretend to all of his
friends he likes her but when it came
when he had the opportunity to do
something about it wouldn't do it it's
the most hypocritical thing I mean that
we could talk about this for hours it
makes me stabby with rays there's a
wonderful line in your book James that
you say music is the one trustworthy
thing that there is and we're taking it
away from an entire generation of
children yeah Armando you have been very
open in the book about the fact that for
years you've basically been a listener
yes you can't just sit at the piano and
do that though you want to see that that
weren't happening then when you were 40
your wife bought you a piano for your
birthday and there's a hilarious
vignette of you sitting in someone's
kitchen about a year later sitting on a
very low blue plastic chair clutching
your sheet music amongst the load of
seven year olds because you were as I
lose it to you in the introduction about
to take your grade one piano yes at 40
did you think it was time well I mean it
was a president I didn't know I I worked
deadlines I always have done that's how
I you know I write pieces to a deadline
you know you're doing a TV show there's
a sort of weekly connector that's just
how I function I thought the only way
I'm going to make myself learn he's by
giving myself something to work towards
so I applied for grade one I signed up
with a music a piano teacher well you do
realize that when you're a bit more
grown-up you you you you're a bit more
in control so it does take a bit of the
pressure off because every time I went
to see my piano teacher and say did you
practice this week I'd go no I'm paying
for it what are you going to you know
you've got to keep me in after school
you know so I I did this and I and I I
made myself go for great one and I
didn't realize that a lot of these exams
are held in people's houses and there I
was sitting in a tiny little thanks to
all the and you know a magnificent piece
of Chopin was being played next door and
I walks a five-year-old and that's where
I did and and what I hadn't realized was
that
what I'd being practiced on was this was
a digital keyboard with the soft keys
and then I'd go in and it's something
like that and it's like I picked up a
trombone I thought it was like a
completely different instrument because
just the touch was much heavier and I
haven't practiced that there was a
little tiny plastic keyboard in the
kitchen like one of these little kind of
electronic things that primary school
teachers who play the wheels on the bus
on that you were meant to kind of warm
up on but you know so I hadn't really
and I just started laughing during it
because I just thought this is
ridiculous because you know I've I've
won a BAFTA i I've done I've done live
television it was fine
I'm banned in Russia but this is I've
been bandura you know and I just and the
only thought that kept me going was I
once I think when I was about 30 I
joined an improvers swimming cause
because I could never really I missed
that lesson at school where they taught
you how to dive in and do the crawl and
stuff look at that and and it was good
but it was full of midlane middle-aged
men mostly who were used to being able
to order people around you know kind of
mostly naked in a pool being told what
to do by an 18 year old with a whistle
and the ones that were bad at it
couldn't cope with being bad and there
was one guy during the crawl there was
one guy who just shouted aerodynamically
this just isn't possible and the 18 year
old saying well people have been doing
it for thousands here and he just
refused and he got up and he lagging and
he never came back so as I was doing
this I was thinking I mustn't be like
that we must get through this and I
passed by one round of applause
[Applause]
but I've kind of forgotten in that
because I follow up habits so which is
why I'm going to take up the well I was
gonna say learn the piano challenge well
James you've dedicated a whole book to
the idea that actually anyone can play
their own unders good example of this
yeah beautiful book how to play the
piano does what it says on the track of
marketing genius marketing my book about
guitar poetry no the idea it's got bark
at its heart and why bar Viper for the
idea that anyone can play well they're
two approaches to learning an instrument
there's the thing that sends shivers
down our spine of being a kid and having
to do scales and and I can't tell you
how many people come up to me after
concerts and say that was awful no they
push their kids up to me and they say
you gotta tell Charlie he's got a
practice his scales I don't know you
practice your is good what with
that it's not necessary that Autzen you
can go down that route scales and
arpeggios playing pieces that you really
don't like cause your teachers forcing
and exams and the pressure that or what
if you just want to play one piece of
music a really beautiful simple piece of
music in this case a Prelude by bar
written 300 years ago that's still today
you play and people just go ah that's
amazing and it's not particularly hard
it's a question of logic and physics and
so I wrote a book I figured six weeks
forty minutes a day you have Sundays off
it teaches you how to read music teaches
you which fingers to use how to use the
pedal you do two bars a day six weeks
later you're playing a piece of bark and
it's absolutely trigger sent videos from
people on Twitter who maybe they used to
play when they were a kid and they
didn't play for 30 years and they
started again because they regretted it
or they've never played and they buy a
30 quid keyboard off Amazon and now
they're playing a piece of bar because
pick a wine bar because when you get
home after a hard day at the office
you can watch love Ireland
eating chicken from a bucket I mean what
the
or you can find 40 minutes with a little
keyboard maybe with your kid or your
girlfriend or your boyfriend and do
something that is extraordinary I think
you're a hero they're little I want to
hear how funny would it be if I screw
this up could you write it up but it's
it's two minutes unless two minutes long
so listen to this piece and bear in mind
it's it's eminently doable for every
single person in this hall tonight
[Music]
you
I think the really important point about
that is that we're so used to doing
everything with an app and you know if a
web page doesn't load in half a second
we move on to something up the idea of
just having a book and spending 40
minutes and you literally you need two
hands and a keyboard and anyone can do
that in six weeks but without changing
you know why enough stay with us you
should how romantic and passionate back
is because people have this image of
back as being rigid and cool and
mathematical but that's the other point
that logic and physics but this is a
really cool isn't it geez there are so
many different ways to play this piece
and again you can play it super cold
like
or you can go the other extreme and play
a super romantic
right as a girl you like and you want to
really and but you can you can you can
do it with our pedal
[Music]
you can use a lot of pedal there's so
many different ways of doing it and
there's no wrong way like no one can say
to you that's the wrong way to do it and
that's another reason I chose bath
because bar never gave tempo indications
or dynamic indication sometimes he
didn't even say what bloody instrument
it should be played on so really you can
play at how are you want what a lovely
thing yeah to have that freedom because
you know it's ironic that he perhaps
above all other composers its policed by
oh my god this guy right he was like a
baroque make Jagger he had 20 children
like really like shagged his way around
all but but 11 of them died in infancy
or childbirth when he was four like half
of his siblings have died at nine his
mum died at ten his father dies he
shipped off to live with an elder
brother he's beaten so badly at school
he's absent for more than half of his
school days because they abuse going on
there as a teenager he walks hundreds
walks walks hundreds of kilometres to go
to school to study music as a teenager
and he marries the love of his life she
dies half their kids die and you say oh
no bark isn't romantic he's very kind of
just rhythmical and mathematical I'm
sorry it had to come out someone yeah
you spent some time in prison as well
yeah because he wouldn't compose what
the court wanted him to and he was
drooling he was arrested for shagging
groupies in the organ loft I mean the
guy was really he was he was a prayer
I've been there anti-social behaviour
orders yeah certain an ADEA would have
definitely got one but it's so
interesting possible a basketball he's
held up as you say when you mentioned
logic he went in physics as this
supremely mathematical composer because
yeah the complexity of Bach's fugue the
complexity of lots of his music is is
there there is a lot of massive he was
obsessed with numbers he added on his
name that the initials the letters in
his name corresponding to the code in
the alphabet a is 1 B is 2 and if you
add them all up you get 41 4 & 1 you
reverse it you get 40 I mean but I told
you where mental news and he he would
use these little ciphers there would be
you know 41 bars in a piece or after six
Barr's he wrote six of everything six
english sweet six party - six french
sweet six brandenburg concerto six cello
suites he was obsessed with numbers and
yeah at the same time the depth of
feeling the heroism that the grief that
the spare the happiness to everything it
all goes into it he's undoubtedly well
in my view the greatest and most people
would accept that he's one of the greats
but in general is there a problem with
the idea of a cannon that is as i say
sort of policed by people who go these
are the great composers and anyone else
around the secondary cuz i wonder this
is a point that you make your range of
musical heroes in the book is astounding
Ligety as you say defective discovered
as a teenager to marta new to the
forgotten british symphonies william
Alwyn any other william Alwyn
enthusiasts in the room great film
composer as well yes celebrity
enthusiast right here but that really
arises from that thing of not having a
structured plan by which i was taught in
that i had to arrive at it myself i had
to get in you know i love Marla and part
of the reason I love Marla was I was
allowed to take out three disks with my
ticket but Marla brought such long
symphonies they were double albums so I
was like I'd cracked a system I was
taking out for you know I thought we'll
try that and I fell over because it was
just this amazingly passionate dramatic
over-the-top sentimental but yet also
really intellectual as well music and I
and I one thing would then suggest
another so you know Marla woods if
people would talk about Bruckner so
listen to Bruckner didn't quite get into
him but it listened to in bargain and
see the correlation between the two
pardonnez opera Benjamin Britten all
prepared you know it's it just it you
know everything you know connects with
something else and and so you don't it's
not let you start at the beginning and
work your way through but you you just
dive in and that's the great joy for me
is that it is unquantifiable because
there is there is more of it you think
you can ever possibly hear and that
means you don't actually have to like
everything you hear well don't like
saying I love books I love old books and
of all the books I've read a great
you know you'll come across stuff that
doesn't it doesn't click with you in
turn and that's fine you know you're not
less of a classical music enthusiast for
not liking something well I want to
bring us to Mozart because we're you do
agree that bark is the greatest you
rather diverge on the subject of Mozart
and intelligent squares of course is
famous for its wonderful debates I'm not
sure we can get a debate going here but
I'm and I just want to quote you if I
may I've never been able to sit through
a production of The Magic Flute without
thinking it's the silliest messiest
story I've ever seen I've gone off in a
huff and put some vogner on instead
James meanwhile you described listening
obsessively to a certain pair of Mozart
operas you say these to a by Mozart
which helps the biggest deterrent to
opera for me is vogner disgusting no
quite quite seriously though Mozart I'm
Andy make a very serious point with that
in a playful way of course by pointing
out that actually you really struggle to
get to a point where you just appreciate
I'm still I'm I'm I like moths I'm
warming to him I still think I need a
bit more encouragement a bit of help but
I'm especially the later more tightly
it's difficult to say later when he died
at whatever 35 but the music he was
writing near the end of his life what I
think for me was as I was starting out
and listening and it may just be that
kind of reaction to what you're told
everyone was telling me and I remember
listening to on radio 3 that Bernard 11
doing a talk and interval talk where he
actually praised to the God matza quite
seriously and and I I sort of I think
maybe I just react against it because I
didn't get it it seemed to me like a
kind of the motor I heard seemed like
you know variations on twinkle twinkle
little star I felt sugary and too nice
you know that's how I felt
now subsequently I've come across one of
the most amazing opera productions ever
went to was the Magic Flute done by in
conjunction with Eno and theatres and
complicity
I've also walked out of Vienna Opera for
just be
to watch it was all set in a Barret home
and the whole thing rests on you
believing that the gods or the gods
believe you put them in a Barrett home
you've kind of yeah negated the next
column I know so you know and and and
that's the other thing I just want to
say it's evolving taste is evolving you
don't you mustn't stick with what new
liked when you were fifteen sixteen and
that's it and that's and that's actually
why I for me
classical music is more enriching than I
don't get that buzzer pop music or rock
music we're in that for me that music
seems connected with a particular point
in time in your life or a particular
memory or and and but with classical
music it's it feels to be timeless it's
it feels like you're still learning and
finding new pieces even though those
pieces might be four hundred years old
and even if it's the same piece actually
you're always finding new
interpretations James yes you write so
convincingly and compellingly about a
particular interpretation of these notes
yes and I wanted to talk to you bit
about the importance of the interpreter
and tell us about you young Greek god
Theodore currants this and why it makes
such a difference to hear him conduct
note so yeah there is a guy at the
moment on the scene he for my money the
the the greatest living conductor and I
don't say that lightly I mean he he's
only released a small number of albums
but amongst those are three of the
Mozart operas and they are the only
recordings I've ever heard of any
composer by any performer where you just
know when you're listening to it this is
what Mozart heard in his head while he
was writing it down I don't know where
to start with Mozart I mean I'm not
religious at all but that he is proof of
God and you say you can say that study
Shakespeare and he'll show us who we are
but if you study Mozart he'll show us
who we could be potentially if some
unbelievable miracle half
and Syria you can buy his complete works
on CD on amazon their 180 cds get 180
cds he died at 35 he started composing
at 5 so in 30 years he produced the
equivalent of 6 albums a year think
about that for a minute from the age of
five can you think of a single
contemporary artist who could maintain
even two albums a year for 30 years that
you'd want to listen to and then even
more you think about the fact that and
that would get better big well actually
it does get better but there are also
moments that by his second piano
concerto his second piano concerto he
was 11 has a slow movement that it it
just shreds your heart I mean I can't
tell you so yet on the one hand maybe it
gets better on the other hand it's
already there like a lot of you will
know the story that when he was a very
young teenager 13 14 his dad took him to
a church and he heard a choir singing
and they were singing Miserere by a
composer called a library and in that
day sacred music music and church it was
illegal to take the score out of the
church it was illegal even to look at
the score and Mozart he'd heard this and
he said to his dad you know that
well what is this music
where can I get it and it's dad said I'm
sorry you know it's you can't so the guy
the kid goes home 14 locks himself up in
his attic writes down the entire thing
from memory the organ part the vocal
part everything and says the dead you
know I really wanted to know that score
so I wrote it down so I can study it 41
symphonies 27 piano concertos dozens of
operas 26 string quartet I mean that
there are no words to describe it and
then when you hear someone like tear
dorker Ensis bring it to life those are
literally Don Giovanni Marriage of
Figaro and Cosi Fan Tutte those
recordings of currencies that he's made
are the only recordings I listen to now
on a regular basis there I I don't need
ten desert off any genre
for some that everything you need to
know about the world is in there and I
don't necessarily agree about the
distinction between classical being
richer than other forms I was obsessed
with Wham
when I was a kid I'm sorry and I was
obsessed with Queen and I to me it's the
same thing it releases the same kind of
chemicals and yes classical music
perhaps it's longer it's more complex a
lot of the time it doesn't have words so
you can provide your own story and I
think all of that makes it a slightly
different experience but you know it's
the same 12 times
he's just released the conductor has
just released
Tchaikovsky's sixth symphony the
packaging and on your recommendation I
listen to that on the recommendation of
his if there's one thing we may be home
from today like please listen on Spotify
or iTunes whatever tailored or
occurrences his name is current and then
Z is he's six foot five chain-smoking
he's like Mozart meets Leonard Bernstein
meets Kurt Cobain and he's um he's
revolutionized music and no doubt for a
lot of purists he is end of days and I
talked a bit about gate areas and
particularly around opfer actually when
you mentioned Mozart operas and Wagner
certainly I was put off magnet opera for
so long because I felt that I didn't I
wouldn't take the score in with me I
couldn't in every light motif and the
bars in which there's every production
that has ever been a by Roy I couldn't I
didn't have those reference I can't I
don't know whether that was my reaction
to what I was I pervasive Neapolitan
father who played Puccini and Verdi all
weekend very very loudly and and again I
don't know whether that's me going okay
I can't have that then because that's
someone else's what can I have you know
what's the opposite what's the opposite
of Puccini
now Chile's glorious actually absolute
it's that it's that thing of how your
tastes are shaped by what you're made to
feel at the time you know and there's a
fabulously satirical chapter in your
book about a Night at the Opera which
also includes the portrait over the sort
of classical tyrannical opted from my
stro how much do you think classical
music is compromised by or even ruined
perhaps in the eyes of potential
audiences by those stereotypes by those
tropes I mean they they're grounded in
truth unfortunately well yeah I mean
that's what we were saying at the start
isn't it it's it's I mean you want I
think the reason that that recording
says so much is that there's someone who
is starting afresh with the score and
okay okay as you say what's it like to
almost to recreate that impression of
having heard this music for the for the
very first time exactly and I think
that's what everyone has to do every
player has to do it every orchestra
every interpreter has to do it but what
you get or think in some of these
institutions is know you've got to know
exactly what you're going to getting in
advance and you've got to have
complainants normal yeah you know a lot
of it's down to the performers as well I
mean I I've played it sonar festival
Latitude Festival and played to
audiences that have been so much quieter
and more respectful than the Barbican or
the further it's it's it doesn't make it
the majority of classical concerts today
in my experience honestly I would rather
sit at home and listen to Spotify than
them pay forty five quid go to the
public and at 8:30 in the evening
starving hungry in the rain and listen
to two and a half hours of music and
where they're all of these rules that
seem to apply and the performers you go
to a piano recital the guy walks on
ridiculous outfit and he scales at you
and it sits down and he plays and then
he scales and then he goes home and you
say well okay I mean I mean of course
I'll always go to that because it's
kissing or soccer lovers and I love
these guys they're my heroes but what I
would give to hear one of them just
spend three minutes
saying I'm gonna play you this piece by
Beethoven and when he composed that he
just got a new piano and it's like a kid
getting a new wife and the enthusiasm
you can have from the opening chords it
had more sounds it had a different pedal
it had more notes and just to hear why
playing it that's me and it makes all
the difference why you're such a gem
James Rhodes and we're going to get you
to tell us about your next piece which
is based on opera originally comes from
Orfeo AEG Lee look this is the ultimate
love something yeah so this opera or
fear in your radicchio and you most of
you will know the story we're all fear
the love of his life she dies and the
Greek could they take her down to hell
you're a DJ and he goes come on God
please you know she's so young I loved
us so much let me go down and rescue her
and they say okay but if you find her
you can bring her back to the real life
but you can't turn and look at her while
you're leading her back I mean cuz they
were dicks to gods they just like
playing these little games and so he
they say if you turn and look at her
she'll die instantly so he goes down to
the underworld and he finds her and he's
leading her back and of course she's
getting more and more absurd she's
thinking why isn't he looking at me like
I've I got fat he's is it it's like it
kind of you know if they were
Millennials should be saying come on
let's take a selfie with our selfie
stick for it very Instagram anyway he
ends up he does he turns and looks at
her and she's killed instantly
to be fair anyone using a selfie stick
should be killed instantly I think but
but it ends up OK in the end they bring
her back to life because they realized
love is important and anyway this piece
of music is what accompanies him as he
goes down to find her at the start of
his journey he doesn't know if he'll
find her he doesn't know if he'll
survive he doesn't know if he'll live or
die and so ostensibly it's quite a dark
piece and yet this is the magic trick
with classical music that I don't get
from other forms underneath the sadness
there is so much love and joy and
surrender and hope and positivity the
it's like a it's sad but it's flavoured
with so much more depth than that so
this is an arrangement by an italian
composer called giovanni scam batty if
if people care about things like that
[Music]
you
[Applause]
your book is incredibly open about the
hell of being on tour and of the
particular nerves and horrors for you of
performance day and I imagine that a
piece like that which so exemplifies
beauty so exemplifies stillness it's a
great ally when I see your sort of
mental and spiritual health and I wonder
if you could talk a little bit more
about how music gets you through life
because you you credit it with your life
literally yeah and maybe that sounds a
bit melodramatic but I don't think I
mean and I think I'm far from unique in
that I got life without music there
being conceivable to all of us and and
also when you say the hell of touring I
should be abundantly clear you know it's
really not an important job that I have
it's really a lot of fun and there it's
what I wanted to do since I was I'm one
of the lucky ones
I'm like one of those kids who was
obsessed with football and finds himself
playing alongside Messi and Ronaldo and
wakes up and goes how did this happen
and bring with it certain pressures and
responsibilities to that it does yeah
but I think the truth is every I think
it's it depends how you're wired I you
won't believe me but it's the absolute
truth I feel I feel the same anxiety
about playing in front of two and a half
thousand people that I saw that concert
from memory a hundred thousand nodes as
I did when I used to work in Burger King
when I was a teenager I promised you
would I burn the burgers would I get
fired would I get too overwhelmed am I
gonna be on time am I gonna be late and
I gonna get paid on time and the
customers gonna be not the same kind of
just it's the same am I gonna remember
is the piano gonna be okay as the
audience gonna be that's just the way I
am and touring is tricky because it's
lonely and lots of jetlag and and and
all you audiences don't care they don't
care if you've been on a plane for 14
hours and it's four o'clock in the
morning body clockwise they you know
they paid their ticket and then I have a
have a good time and and there's also
the idea that I'm playing pieces that I
have worshipped and worship in a way
that you can't imagine
they're just the greatest part of my
life for so long and now I'm the handed
guy on stage playing it saying listen to
this listen to what Beethoven wrote out
of his mind with grief of course there's
a certain I mean with a healthy dose of
perspective that there's a certain
amount of pressure that comes from that
I don't want to that than that and you
always let them down because the bar is
up here the bar a pianist like our
garage and Sokolove and if I do a
concert with a hundred thousand notes
and three of those notes I've put three
grams more weight on one finger
the concerts ruined genuine and that's
where that's the perfect concert is it's
answer you never get that so you're
always falling slightly short and you
always feel like a bit of a fraud and
it's never quite good enough agaric and
Sokoloff never feel they get there
though no Sokka though doesn't think
that either
I think that's it's just it's just that
it's a like any job it's difficult it's
also something about doing that it's the
lack of you're not in control and it's
never you're at the mercy of the theater
the cinema it's gonna ask you I'm and
also a lot no do you find that you also
turn to music not is not in that way but
no I am what I suffer from badly is
jetlag I'm just you know which is why I
stopped doing veep in the end that and
United Airlines lack of ability to say
sorry many many times and but I did
carry up when I was out in Baltimore a
lot I did carry this sir Brennan
you know this hard drive with all my CD
collection on it and I I spent about
four months loading it up I seen I
brought it with me and it was a it was a
godsend because you're out of sync
you're you know you're in a different
place you don't know anyone and you know
you're doing this thing it gives your
show and there is a lovely thing it's
like talk radio I will always be so
grateful for talk radio when you're
lonely and it's 4:00 in the morning and
you want to blow your brains out and you
turn on the radio and you have someone
chatting to you I did that so many times
either on tour when I was a teenager and
it's the same with music every night
before bed when I was a kid I would put
on a
CD or cassette or whatever of Horovitz
or gills or Kissin and I would close my
eyes and I would pretend that was me
playing and if it was a live I'm even
better because you'd get the applause
and I'd be lying there going yes didn't
they do great and I was a weird kid but
it was amazing it was amazing and it has
the same effect now and in the morning I
I always put on a piece of bark just odd
I mean Spotify is great actually thank
you Radio 3 breakfast yes if the jetlag
kick - then I'm up at 4 a.m. but also
you never play the same piece rice you
can study a Beethoven sonata for 25
years and still discover new things and
different ways to play it and different
things that you want to do it's and
there's a lot of I mean how do you know
what you're doing is right it's why so
many classical musicians rerecord the
same pieces after 10 years or 20 years
because you listen to her and you think
oh what was I thinking they weren't you
know is completely wrong it has to be
this way now and also we forget how
different concerts were you know when
Beethoven is doing a constant I mean
this was the only time they could hear
the music in school recordings so he'd
play a piece and if they like the
movement they'd applaud they say do it
again do it again and the concert would
go on for like five hours and would come
and go Oh Graham these mental concerts
that had like four symphonies and all ya
know concerto of my favorite beethoven
concert story this is a bit geeky but
it's really fun no pressure
his crusty shut up his first caricature
- first piano concertos in C major very
beautiful lovely happy piece and at the
premiere he was doing the solo part and
conducting and the copyist was writing
it out and it was so - the wire they
didn't have time to rehearse or anything
they get there they're handing out the
pin for the orchestra that the sheet
music and the inks still wet and they're
about to start and they realized that
the piano is at half a tone outta tune
with the rest of the orchestra and so
what he does Beethoven as he goes along
instead of playing his own first piano
concerto in C major he plays it in C
sharp major on the fly can you I mean
any musicians here would just go holy
I mean that
insane I love that Beethoven and for me
he is the bass he's the best he's
greater than bark he's greater he's
greater than all of them
that leaves us rather beautifully to our
final piece we open it out to the
audience and you're going to tell us
about a particular sonata by Beethoven
yeah it's not really a I'm not gonna
play because it's long it's like 22
minutes long but I wanted to give you
and I have recorded actually I'm signing
CDs after it's my CDs so it can is it on
this one I can't yes it is on this one
so you've got um it's his 31st piano
sonata like what have you done today
right but we're only 32 sonatas holy
but I'm going to give you a couple
of examples from this piece I just when
you think it's hard to put into words at
the opening it's so condensed that the
first three bars here we are
[Music]
that's the first three bars and within
those three bars is almost all the
thematic material from the first
movement parts of the second movement
and almost all the thematic material of
the last movement condensed and it's the
last movement that I want to talk about
I'm gonna there moments would be with
this piece where time just stands still
right there's no movement at all and
there's like at the opening I'm gonna
play you the opening as he wrote it and
you're here after about 40 seconds
there's an a a single note and he
repeats it like 28 times at this point
in his life he's completely deaf he's
sick this is the only piece he writes in
1820 he knows he's got he's sick with
the illness that's going to end up
killing him and he's desperately alone
and he goes inside and and this is like
it's like reading his diary this is what
he writes this is the last movement just
the opening of it
[Music]
that's the introduction and then he
writes what he calls his song of
lamentation which is like the proper
theme and just listen to the listen to
the the grief in this
[Music]
and it carries on in that vein but then
the magic happens you think it can't get
any sadder and it has to end and then he
writes a fugue which I show you this is
important how he ends this movement
[Music]
so we think it's gonna get happier now
and actually it does if the few
progresses this is kind of a standard
and you think this is going to be the
end of the whole Sonata and then he
pulls this unbelievable kind of plot
twist the whole thing gets really kind
of loud and rambunctious and you think
it's the end but it isn't so listen to
what he does
[Music]
[Applause]
he goes back to the original sad theme
but ornamented and he writes at the top
exhausted like he's got nothing left in
him and you hear in the music you hear
him gasping for breath like he can
barely breathe listen to this
[Music]
the whole thing just it's like it's the
most intimate he gets so then here's my
favorite bit and then I'm gonna finish
and we'll talk about something else but
do you remember how we ended last time
listen to what he does now I'm gonna
play exactly as written I promise you
I'm not changing anything
[Music]
you
now we recognize that few firstly those
chords it's like Jesus dying on the
cross in his mind and then he writes
little by little gaining new life coming
back to life we think we know it
[Music]
and then he spends the rest of the
moment turning it back the right way
around until it ends in this blaze of
glory it's incredible
even the ending from from being so
desperately sad it's like
[Music]
the whole thing is all about his
Redemption and just finally just to
finish because this is a little touch
that makes me so happy even if no one
else here only gets it the end of the
first movement rate this is way before
that feud that we talked about the very
end of the movement listen to this
[Music]
and you don't think you notice anything
about that
but I'm gonna put three grams more
weight on my thumb when I play it and
listen to what happens
[Music]
here it's the feud
so right from the start we have so you
can study a piece like this for for 20
years and in every bar there is so much
to learn and to discover which is why
you need a teacher and not one who's
going to force you to do scales but one
who's going to really enjoy kind of
digging into stuff like that this is why
we all need James Rhodes ladies and
gentlemen
[Music]
[Applause]
we've got about 15 minutes for your
questions for Armando and James there
are two stand mics in the gallery so if
you are in the gallery and you would
like to ask a question please line up
indecorous fashion at these Dan likes
and then we've got ashes down here as
well so I'll take questions in there
batches of two or three so any questions
for James or Armando or both over there
we'll take one and then down here
gentlemen in the front and the blue if
we can get the microphone Tim thank you
very much indeed and up in the gallery
anyone at the stand mic yes okay let's
start in the gallery
well they have to get up and do the walk
oh oh you've got to do the walk of shame
all right we'll start down here first
and then get yourselves over to the mic
right gentlemen thank you very much I
thought that was fantastic
I've always loved music Miserere is one
of my favorite pieces Ling Google's
Goldberg Variations you know all that
stuff just just makes me feel wonderful
you know when I was 14 I could recite
every single Chuck Berry lyric and you
know Goldberg variation would have just
gone straight over my head and you know
by the time I was 19 I was a roadie for
The Clash you know and you know when I
hear you know anarchy in the UK it's
still like it's like a shot of
adrenaline it's amazing but and it is
spiritual I mean it's all spiritual but
you know maybe trying to force-feed kids
classical musical which that doesn't
necessarily appeal to them is the wrong
way and maybe you know the Stratocaster
is the gateway drug to the Stradivarius
yeah I couldn't agree more it's not
about force-feeding I mean any feeding
would be great to be honest with you I
don't think there is for that we do you
know but it is but it's about music it's
not
about saying listen to Bruckner for 70
minutes or I'm going to smell it's about
all of it it's how bar leads directly to
Mozart and Haydn that leads to bathe him
that ends up with Justin Bieber it
doesn't it's how you get there that is
equally about listening to Lana Del Rey
is equally valid as listening to beta I
would never dare tell an eight-year-old
kid that somehow Justin Bieber is less
worthy of her time or attention dan dan
bar it's it's about music . what makes
up how do you read music how do you play
the piece she wants to play on the piano
it's why if you have a kid and you're
taking them to music lessons and they
really don't want to play Clemente or
Mozart let them play the theme from The
Simpsons let them play whatever they
want because it's about enjoying it so I
would agree we mustn't force-feed them
and I've just think James after that you
talked us through the NASA there that it
reminded me that one of the things that
I cannot say to people who say how
directly into classical music where
should I start so I can see although
we've spent a little bit of time signing
off go to a concert because actually
there's something about watching it live
it is a drama whether it's it's one
person or an orchestra you can actually
in an office you can actually see the
music move around go to the prom these
days I think no go to the prom I think
absolutely get it right yeah it's the
biggest music festival in the world it's
one of the only places where you wear
what you want you clap when you want you
don't have to know anything about it you
can get tickets for a fiber you can have
it at lunchtime you can have it in the
evening in a bit late night it's a
promise I'm not even paying in a bitter
it's it's incredible if you don't know
about classical music how do you know
where to start you look at the Southbank
web website how'd you know which
conductor to see which Bruckner symphony
to see which can share to see you and I
wouldn't know where to start with that
stuff tell me about the focus actually
as well when you're when you're a live
orchestral contour inspector concert you
the mind you can you can remember the
music you can see the structure you
think better when you're when you're
watching it in front of you good take
this said there was question and then
hopefully there's someone in the gallery
thank you
hi this is a question for James thank
you for picking such
election are very similar taste but
music music and pianist but I and I'm
very much ellika like you are about
music I'm having this challenge
communicating to non classical music
lovers of wonder if you can help me with
I find increasingly if I play something
to a friend like recommend of B minor
Prelude that things in a minor key and
you chose almost all minor key things
tonight and are increasingly getting a
response as depressing and I find minor
key music very uplifting and I can see
that you do too but increasingly I find
that kind of the young audience
interpret a minor key performance as a
depressing and down beat and melancholic
thing and then they're not getting joy
from the sadness that I think audiences
use news I don't understand why I wonder
how you would communicate that through
words
that's a great question it's interesting
isn't it we tend to associate major key
with happy and minor key was sad and yet
they're so many different flavors of sad
and I mean God although anyone would
find that right man I'm not really like
suicide ly depressing that'd be right I
mean God it just it makes me want to
throw myself out a window and I'm not
really sure how to once that except is
to say look at bigger pieces instead of
that praline play them the second piano
concerto for example which has just the
most bombastic ending which I you know
you'd have to have a heart of stone not
to get you know even a semi-hard on when
you're listening to it but but also it
also has a slow movement that's
incredibly intense and and brooding and
mysterious and and also what's this / we
have some how to sadness like what's
wrong with being said we had this idea
is if we've kind of caught that awful
American thing of the pursuit of
happiness like it's the most important
thing and it comes from a new iPhone or
a new tinder date or whatever the
it what's wrong with just feeling a
little bit sad like that it's that's
absolute it's normal it's totally normal
and the truth is one more thing before
used to know and the hope that was sad
it's over
oh no no that I I would say to them that
when you listen to music it tends to
turn the volume up on whatever it is you
are feeling as a listener
I am I experience music does not make
you feel a certain way because of the
music itself but it it grows whatever it
is you're feeling so I would say maybe
the people who say that maybe they're
just all really depressed happier people
I wasn't going to say I was just going
to say that I mean isn't isn't teenage
angst and emotion isn't that a very kind
of typical teenage you know I I think
people some of the music I listen to
when I start out listening to classical
music was the sad music was the very
slow extraordinary end of Marla's Ninth
Symphony which is like 15 minutes of
extremely sad music that then disappears
and the last minute of it is is is a
kind of musical version of silence
really just it justice it's very sad but
until you just drawn to that as well as
two kind of joyful jetting teenagers
just substitute humans I think you know
there is something question in the
gallery where are you here you are I
think I'm a I'm a pianist as well and
graduated Royal College very confused
until I started introducing my concerts
and then I felt I'm really connecting
with the audience much better so the
virus is spreading if you were given all
sort of support financial social
psychological mental support if you need
one to write new syllables for ABRSM or
Trinity what would you do well it
wouldn't consist of scales I suppose and
it wouldn't it would consists of the
third or as recordings what else would
be there the ABRSM say and for those who
don't know it's that it's the standard
exams that kids taken and students take
her kids an Armando and I'm Alan well I
would
I'm not a music teacher so I I wouldn't
know I don't think it's my place to
answer if I had a choice what I would
say as I would have polish all of it and
I would judge it based entirely on the
performance that the student gives there
was a piano competition that evapo
Garelick
founded a long time ago he's one of the
great pianists he's gone a little bit
crazy sadly but he was at one time the
greatest living pianist there's no
question and he started a competition
and all competitions have choices of
repertoire you have to choose they give
you a list and you have to choose what
you're going to play there's no way
around it in every single round all the
way through to the final and they give
you a choice of concertos and you do it
and he said you play anything you want
and we judge you based on your
musicianship and I think it has to be
that it has to be that you you you play
the pieces you want to play and you have
a teacher or a juror who is emotional
enough and sensitive enough to actually
decide I'm going to judge this based on
how it makes me feel and how much the
kid is enjoying it rather than whether
he uses his fourth finger instead of his
third and hits a be naturalness set of a
b-flat cuz honestly they're bigger
things to worry about and also could
could exam boards please bear in mind
that there are kind of adults yeah it
gets some bigger chair I've had to spend
five months learning you know farmer
jawed kins tractor is something anyone
else up in this side of the gallery make
your way to the mic we'll take this
question here thank you very much yeah
my name is Francis um I've really loved
your talks all three of you it was very
very interesting um I am NOT a musician
at all and so absolutely brilliant to
hear you guys talk and to play I have a
question for Armando and just interested
in kind of sort of the topic is a
transformation transformative power of
music and how music has transformed your
writing or if it's transformed your
writing and your work in television and
fit alright yes well it's sort of it's
sort of hands without it being very
specific about it but I mean I always
work with music on ER and I always
have a sense of I think what I've gained
for music there's a sense of structure
you know I
there's something very there's something
very musical about comedy in any of you
if you get if you get geeky comedy
writers together and they'll talk about
how it's important you can have
arguments that can go on for an hour
about where the funny word should come
in the sentence there's something if you
move it from that point to maybe the end
or the joke is ruined there's something
about the timing the rhythm of of a
funny line and open it up there's
something about the timing or structure
or rhythm of a funny plot that has to
have a satisfying rhythm it has to build
up it has to just when you've forgotten
something that was referred to earlier
suddenly it comes as you open the door
there it is and there's just an and I
for me it helps to think of it in terms
of music and and I did one episode of
the thick of it which I think it was the
figure yeah where I just thought
actually this episode we're going to
write as a fugue we're gonna we're going
to do this and then it's going to have
in a bit again later well they've moved
on and then the same things gonna happen
again for the third time well they you
know and that says no you not need to
know that but just that's that's how it
affects me and which episode is it I'm
told I'm falling it was funny
Radio 5 Live falling really another
question over here thank you thank you
um in 1956
I finished teacher training college
having done three years at Weiser
college and went off to be teacher to
teach music in secondary schools no I
didn't teach music it was music studies
we didn't do any of it we learnt we
taught how to read music and the game in
terms of listening to music was if if if
you listen to one of mine listen to one
of yours so they would bring in
something and we listened to it and we
played for something in 1989 Luton
Authority and started teaching music in
second in junior schools and I taught
instrumentally purportedly to children
whose parents paid and some class work
and discovered that their total
knowledge of classical music was posh
builds cannon the water music the
planet's sweet and
Carnival of animals and that was it and
then later on I think you said 2012 I
think was early on that something
happened every child in secondary and
junior school children learn instrument
at Key Stage two and yes it did happen
boat though the instruments came in from
China and we had a go we did it
subversively it was the only way we
could do it because that the head that
said no thank you to your loads of money
wouldn't accept that that would accept a
little piece of music going on
so yes three minutes of ukulele isn't
great I was doing recorder and clarinet
on things half an hour isn't great but
it's a damn sight better than talking
about it and listening to it but
actually doing it don't think that's the
important you actually do it as opposed
to just consume it I agree but there was
a huge problem
the hub's were introduced around them
and there were hubs in all over the
country where all of these instruments
from China went to and none of the hubs
have a communication system and no one
was really in charge and the Arts
Council didn't know who had what and
schools didn't know how many instruments
they had and of course it's a
generalization to say it just didn't
happen my experience is that it was a
very very much a postcode lottery to the
point that by the time they get to
secondary school fewer than 10% of
children are recorded as having learnt
an instrument for a year so some schools
have amazing music some state schools
have amazing music but they are very a
tiny tiny minority in my experience but
of course you're right it's much better
to have some access to an instrument
than just listening to something we take
one more question thank you very much so
well this is embarrassing though I only
thought I would say this because I've
driven three hours here and I don't know
a single person in this room you are
among friends so last year I was not
very well and spent some time in a
psychiatric hospital we're listening to
music was actually really hard to do and
as a musician a professional musician
and music teacher play three instruments
music has always been my life and for a
while the idea of even listening to
music let alone playing anything
was just impossible I just wondered if
you've ever experienced sometimes there
are really great things that you
discover about listening and playing
music when you're not well
has it ever really been a house it had
like a negative impact on you
what a lovely question thank you fellows
psych ward as well I did I wish I wish
they did loyalty cards you know yeah to
answer your question yes and that's the
scariest thing of all when what you've
loved and believed in all of your life
suddenly threatens to turn on you and
you think oh what if I can't do this
anymore where actually I mean in a way
with hindsight it's not a bad thing
because how many people have something
they care so deeply about and so
passionately about that it has that
amount of power over you it's actually
it's a good thing for me now looking
back that there were moments where I
thought I just can't do it it's too
painful to listen to it and it I guess
it goes back to what I said earlier
about turning it
listening to music turns to volume up on
what you're feeling and so of course if
you're prone to depression of you're
feeling depressed or you're feeling in
very low mood or you have suicidal
ideation I mean you listen to certain
pieces of music and inevitably it's it's
dangerous in in fact in two of the
psychiatric wards I was in music wasn't
allowed weirdly you could watch Jeremy
Kyle
[Music]
what a night but I think there's a
reason for that because I think it does
it it does it there's nothing scarier
when you're mentally ill than a feeling
it's my experience whether it's a good
feeling or a Safiya doesn't matter and
listening to music elicits feelings and
so to answer your question yes I have
felt like that but it always passes and
the love always outweighs the the fear
for me I don't know if you have yeah
well I mean music is I mean I'm
different in that music is my career in
music isn't my you know my my first and
last thought in the day and and the a
but when you have those you know when
you have those weird discussions in your
head which sense would I be happy to
lose and not those I mean I think I'd
rather be blind than death because it
just the the connection I that this the
sense that that when you were playing
that the Bay one was thinking how it's
it's a sort of it feels like someone's
talking to you but I don't quite know
what the words are but I can understand
the meaning yeah and that is is sort of
special and indescribable well on that
note thank you so much - Armando
Iannucci James rose to everyone at
intelligence squared and to all of you
for being a fantastic audience thank
[Applause]
you